les voitures incendiées et un centre de
contrôle technique entièrement calciné
le résultat de cinq nuits successives
d'affrontements tendue dans ce quartier
de montbéliard où les forces de l'ordre
ont subi des tirs de mortiers ce
week-end longtemps se dit choqué
certains n'osent même plus sortir de
chez eux passé une certaine heure n'est
pas tranquille
tous les habitants ils n'y sont pas il
se sent pas tranquille même si les uns
on sort de jol le jour en mai la nuit
chaque année chez lui la petite hollande
est le théâtre de violences depuis
plusieurs semaines les dégradations se
multiplient et la situation s'aggrave
la maire de montbéliard implore un
retour au calme chaque jour qui passe je
me demande effectivement
qu'est ce qui va se passer cette nuit
combien de voitures vont brûler et 20
grande crainte c'est qu'un jour
quelqu'un soit blessé
il n'y a aucune raison que des violences
de ce type là pourrissent la vie des
habitants du quartier usage de
projectiles et d'engins pyrotechniques
rend les interventions difficiles très
peu d'interpellations pour l'instant eu
lieu malgré la présence sur place d'une
demi compagnie de crs
nous ce qu'on veut c'est un apport
d'effectifs pour pouvoir répondre
immédiatement mobilisés immédiatement et
apporter une réponse forte forte et
et marquante à toutes ces violences on
attend des ordres clairs et d or de
courageux pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
intervenir
les effectifs de police supplémentaires
devraient néanmoins être envoyés à
montbéliard dans les prochains jours on
peux m'engager devant vous art engagé le
maximum de moyens possibles pour
élucider ces affaires je n'en veux pour
preuve que l'envoi dès demain de
renforts da sûreté départementale
d'officier de police judiciaire de
besançon qui sans sûreté départementale
qui vont aller renforcer les effectifs
des enquêteurs de montbéliard pour
travailler sur ces dossiers et être au
maximum tendue vers leurs résultats une
enquête est actuellement en cours
la police compte notamment sur les
témoignages et moyens vidéo pour
identifier les responsables